Trascrizione: Letizia Garofalo
Revisore: Chiara Mondini
Partiamo con un piccolo sommario.
Vi parlerò di discriminazione e pregiudizi
di diritti oggettivi che mancano
quando fai parte di una minoranza
e dei ruoli all’interno
delle famiglie italiane.
Quando ieri sera ho fatto leggere il mio
TED a una persona di cui mi fido molto,
quindi non c’era tempo per cambiarlo,
una delle più intelligenti che io conosca,
non mi ha detto “Vai Marty, spacca!“,
mi ha detto: “È tutto mischiato,
è un gran casino, ma è giusto così,
perché per te nella tua vita
è tutto mischiato.”
Ok, questa è la mia vita.
Proviamoci, cominciamo.
Il giorno del terzo complimese
dei miei figli,
due gemelli che adesso hanno 13 mesi,
ho partecipato a un evento
poco fuori Milano su temi digitali,
un’oretta di viaggio, un’oretta e mezza.
Un collega, non anziano eh,
più giovane di me,
quando gli ho raccontato di questa
ricorrenza mi ha guardato
un pochettino strano,
io avevo gli occhi lucidi,
tutta emozionata,
e lui un po stupito mi fa:
“Ah! E tu sei qui?”
Ma ci sono rimasta un po’ così.
Quando Giulia e Pietro avevano sette mesi,
ho raccontato alla mia fisioterapista che
avevo appena rinunciato a un viaggio di
lavoro di una settimana negli Stati Uniti.
Lei si è fermata, ha smesso
di torturarmi la schiena e mi ha detto:
" E perché? Mio marito ci sarebbe andato”.
Di nuovo ci sono rimasta un po così.
Ma il giorno del primo compleanno
di Giulia e Pietro, il 10 agosto,
alla fine di un caotico e allegro pranzo,
mio papà si è rivolto a tutti i commensali
e fa: “Perché non usciamo tutti
e lasciamo a casa solo Federica?
Così si riposa un po’.”
Ci sono rimasta un bel po’ così,
e visto che si trattava di mio padre,
questa volta ho pure risposto: “Perché
solo lei? Sempre per la cosa successa
un anno fa?” Che sarebbe il parto.
Ok, ci avete capito poco, molto poco.
Non è colpa vostra, è normale.
La mia famiglia va spiegata.
Non mi piace definirla una famiglia
non tradizionale, come si usa dire,
ma sono consapevole del fatto che,
anche se siamo nel 2023, la mia famiglia
in Italia va spiegata
perchè è composta da due mamme.
Niente è ancora chiaro o scontato
per tutti e per tutte,
a partire dall’uso della parola
più semplice, la più bella in italiano,
forse la più semplice dopo “Ciao”.
L’uso della parola mamma, per me
che Giulia e Pietro non li ho partoriti.
E guardate, il problema delle parole è
Il primo con cui mi sono dovuta misurare,
con cui mi sono scontrata
fin dall’inizio, da prima che nascessero.
Vi racconto questa.
Durante il corso pre-parto le ostetriche
continuavano a parlare di mamme e mariti,
dando fra l'altro per scontato che tutte
le coppie in attesa fossero sposate.
Cioè non esistevano fidanzati,
non esistevano compagni, solo mariti.
Io ho fatto notare, un po’ piccata, che
non potevo essere certo definita marito,
insomma. Loro mi hanno risposto
tranquillissime dicendo che no, non c’era
alcun pregiudizio, che non mi dovevo
preoccupare e non eravamo certo il primo
caso di questo genere.
Allora, visto che il mio lavoro è
scegliere le parole, ho suggerito loro
di usare il neutro partner.
Anche perché, sapete, io non posso
neanche definirmi moglie di Federica,
la mia compagna.
Non ci siamo potute sposare,
in Italia non si può,
abbiamo fatto solo un’unione civile.
La parola corretta in questo
caso neanche esiste.
Ci ho pensato un po eh, “unioncivilata”?
No, direi proprio di no.
Ora, io non credo che le bravissime
ostetriche della Mangiagalli abbiano
iniziato a usare partner, ma dovrebbero,
perché è strano, stupido, difficile e
profondamente sbagliato, doversi
preoccupare in uno dei periodi più
emozionanti della propria vita
di come si viene chiamati.
Ma mi spiace dirvelo davvero,
c'è molto, molto di peggio.
Io in Italia per la legge non esisto come
mamma o come genitore due,
che è un altro modo per definire
il genitore intenzionale in una famiglia
omogenitoriale. Chi è il
genitore intenzionale?
È la persona che con le sue scelte,
insieme al partner, ha contribuito a far
nascere suo figlio o sua figlia e se ne
assume la responsabilità genitoriale,
anche se non ha partorito o non ha
legami biologici con i bambini.
Per la legge italiana, ripeto,
io non esisto.
Giulia e Pietro non sono i miei figli.
Pensate che il giorno prima del parto,
che era programmato,
invece di godermi l’emozione e
prepararmi a entrare nel nostro paradiso,
ho avuto la malaugurata
idea di chiamare la nostra avvocata.
Già avere un’avvocata per formare
una famiglia ve la dice lunga,
e le ho chiesto se avrei potuto dare
anche il mio cognome a Giulia e Pietro.
No?! Dare il doppio cognome è una cosa
che le famiglie possono fare adesso.
Lei mi ha risposto di no e io sono rimasta
arrabbiata, passatemelo, incazzata
fino a tarda sera.
L’avvocata mi ha infatti spiegato che,
anche se si fosse verificato il migliore
dei casi, sarebbe stato rischioso chiedere
anche il doppio cognome, diciamo,
come diritto supplementare.
Il migliore dei casi, che poi si è
verificato, è ora appeso a un filo.
È un iter burocratico che permette
di registrare la mia genitorialità presso
il mio Comune, quindi quello di Milano.
Ogni volta che mi accingo a spiegare
questo iter mi rendo conto che perdo
l’attenzione di chi mi sta ascoltando, e
ormai anche la mia, e soprattutto mi
allontano dal punto, che in realtà è molto
chiaro e facile a dirsi e a spiegarsi.
Bastano forse degli esempi pratici.
Non abbandonatemi, provate a seguirmi.
Quando Giulia e Pietro sono nati, non
abbiamo potuto registrare la nascita in
ospedale, come accade a qualsiasi coppia,
anzi, forse alcuni se lo scordano
addirittura. Abbiamo impiegato un mese
e più per ottenere i codici fiscali.
Con il codice fiscale hai il pediatra
della mutua, senza codice fiscale
vai con quello privato per mesi, e costa!
Per compilare la documentazione
per il congedo di maternità facoltativo
della mia compagna ci sono voluti
mesi, code e attese.
Dobbiamo spesso spiegare le cose a chi
lavora negli uffici pubblici e affidarci
alla loro pazienza, empatia e benevolenza.
Dobbiamo compilare dei documenti
cancellando la parola padre a mano.
Per la nostra famiglia è stato tutto più
difficile, fin dai primi giorni, diverso.
E anche se sulla carta d’identità
di Giulia e Pietro, io adesso figuro come
genitore, da un giorno all'altro potrebbe
arrivarci a casa una lettera che dice che
anche il diritto conquistato grazie al
Comune di Milano, questo che vi ho
spiegato, non è più valido, che io
non sono più la mamma dei miei figli.
È già successo ad altre famiglie, eh.
Le procure, come quella di Padova, quindi
a un passo, per esempio, hanno chiesto
ai tribunali di cancellare le mamme
come me dagli atti di nascita.
Possono farlo perché non c’è alcuna tutela
legale, non c’è una cornice.
Possono dire da un giorno all’altro a un
bambino e a una bambina, magari già di
qualche anno, che una delle due persone
che li accompagna a scuola, in piscina,
che li cambia, li nutre, che si sveglia di
notte per confortarli, magari la prima
che li ha presi in braccio appena nati, è
successo a me, non è più il loro genitore,
è assurdo.
Ma pensate che io a un certo senso a
questo ero preparata. Avevo studiato,
conosco il paese in cui sono nata, vivo
e continuo a vivere nonostante tutto,
lavoro e pago le tasse.
Giorno per giorno, invece, ho scoperto
cosa vuol dire formare una famiglia
in Italia, anche se non omogenitoriale.
Cosa vuol dire essere una donna che
forma una famiglia ed essere una madre.
Anche in questo caso, e anche in questo
caso, mi dispiace dirlo, abbiamo un serio
problema di discriminazione.
Io l'ho visto e lo vedo chiaramente da un
punto di vista abbastanza particolare,
perché come genitore due vivo nei panni
dell’uomo. I panni dell’uomo che con
l’avallo della società, vi assicuro,
sono molto, molto comodi.
Quando sono nati i gemelli io ho goduto
dei dieci giorni di congedo di paternità
pagato previsti per i padri, appunto,
grazie alla mia azienda però eh, perché
ovviamente per legge non posso accedere.
Ok, aggiungendo ferie e permessi sono
rimasta a casa a circa un mese, poco più.
Poi sono tornata al lavoro,
e in sostanza alla mia vita di prima,
mentre sulla mia compagna gravava l’intera
gestione della casa e di Giulia e Pietro.
Sulla carta, lo sapete bene, non è detto
che debba andare così per forza.
I padri avrebbero, hanno la possibilità di
chiedere il congedo parentale facoltativo
pagato al 30%, solito che per legge
io non posso chiedere perché...
Ma, se guardiamo i dati relativi
alle famiglie italiane, nell′80% dei casi
sono le donne a chiederlo.
E soprattutto questa percentuale
stenta a cambiare negli anni.
In Italia, e non lo dico come concetto
generico, ma lo provo sulla mia pelle,
è culturalmente scontato
indipendentemente dal fatto
che l’allattamento sia davvero al seno,
che sia la madre, la gestante,
a rimanere a casa con i figli,
anche per lungo tempo,
senza particolari preoccupazioni
per la sua salute fisica e mentale.
Ricordate la fisioterapista che mi
invitava a andare negli Stati Uniti?
Come avrebbe fatto il marito?
È così: è strano che l’uomo non viaggi,
non si faccia una birra con gli amici
dopo il lavoro, non vada in palestra o non
vada allo stadio, o che non si prenda
del tempo per sé , mentre vedere una donna
che fa queste altre cose è come
passare le unghie su una lavagna.
Ed ecco il collega, no, di cui
vi parlavo all’inizio.
Lui, gli ho detto che
sono diventata mamma,
non sapendo che non ho partorito, si
stupiva nel vedermi partecipare a un
evento dopo soli tre mesi.
Credetemi, ve lo assicuro, io non sono
abituata a lamentarmi o a sentirmi una
vittima, Non lo sono.
Ma quando in una coppia le donne sono due
e hanno già dovuto mettere in conto di
accettare una serie di storture e
discriminazioni, come appunto in una
coppia omogenitoriale, è davvero strano
vivere e accettare una condizione che ne
mette una all'angolo in modo aprioristico.
Ed è facilissimo per me, che osservo
questi disequilibri dal mio punto di
vista, che è anche un pochettino esterno,
rendersi conto del perché poi può andare
a finire che dopo la nascita del primo
figlio, quasi una donna su cinque in
Italia tra i 18 e 49 anni
smette di lavorare.
Ora, ho letto da qualche parte che avere
figli ti rende 100 volte più stanco e
100.000 volte più felice.
Non so se sia per tutti così , ma
io sono completamente d'accordo.
Ci aggiungerei un paio di zeri,
soprattutto nel primo caso,
e moltiplichiamo per due,
visto che i miei sono due.
Il saldo resta positivo.
Ci sono almeno 20 milioni di ragioni per
immaginare, impegnarsi, costruire,
sognare il proprio paradiso.
Ma io è un anno che non faccio che
domandarmi, e quindi lo chiedo in un certo
senso anche a voi, cosa ci sia fuori
dal paradiso delle nostre case.
Quali messaggi stiamo dando
ai nostri figli e figlie?
Che non tutte le famiglie sono uguali?
Che alcune vanno spiegate
un po’ più di altre?
E che, nonostante tutti i discorsi dati,
le preoccupazioni sulla denatalità ,
forse sarebbe meglio che non esistessero?
E alle bambine, alla mia Giulia, stiamo
mostrando che non importa cosa e quanto
studierà , quanto si realizzerà , perché
se un giorno vorrà avere un figlio dovrà
stare un passo indietro rispetto
al compagno o alla compagna,
se sarà lei a partorire?
Che dovrà sempre sacrificarsi
un pochettino in più?
Ecco, io sono contenta di di essere qui,
di poter parlare per dire che secondo me
come singoli e come comunità
non possiamo più permetterci
di ignorare queste domande e il rumore,
soprattutto il rumore che fanno
le risposte che diamo con le nostre
azioni ogni giorno.
Tutti e tutte devono poter
sognare di costruire una famiglia
e poterlo fare senza rinunciare
ai propri diritti
e alla possibilità di scegliere
come gestire la propria vita.
Questa oggi è la mia battaglia, spero
diventi un pochettino anche la vostra, per
permettere a Giulia, Pietro e a tutti gli
altri bambini e bambine di avere la forza
e le spalle coperte per inventarsi,
combattere e vincere le loro di battaglie,
che siano nuove.
(applausi)
Grazie.